yeah no hassles and definitely the same
something that moves them and there
might be hope are becoming you see don't
think I can do it take your crop salted
I won every qualities for absence is
Castle black Sonja's contact hope to do
the emergency evacuation yeah border I
mean are you happy with the tag that is
right yes yeah I'm so rude if you're not
going to make the deputy chairman reader
okay oh it's a oh sorry because we
haven't goodness ranges okay then
nothing is really very cool no no that
was trying to do okay and substitute
medicine long members attending
and you had copies of the minutes of the
last meeting had a little family these
are pretty happy than ice and those as
an accurate record great area okay
declarations of interest right let me
switch me off soon item 6 and maximize
that thank you you know buddy I just
intend to not go through the report lima
lies to pull out some of the salient
pointers for you as we go through and of
course happy to answer any questions at
the NSA if that's helpful just a brief
recap the Maximizer itís project the
asset review project part their forms
there are three projects within that
that theme in the business plan the
asset review the rosters projects and
the major aspects project so the one of
photons line this report is the the
asset review project to the universe's
plan it's just intended as an update and
to give an outline approach of if I
should be looking to take and progress
made to date in terms of the current
asset register published in there's a 10
/ 13 or thought of work wednesday at the
time but with the increased emphasis on
our assets it's only right that we look
that again make sure it stays up-to-date
Sacre and it's a fit for purpose so
we've we've taken the approach along
with other projects with the business
planner for developing a project project
group officer project team as you have
some key officers on there from our
asset management team of planning team
legal and open spaces plus male
colleagues assisting as well and support
from the project office I'd say very
much in the theme of how we're looking
to run their projects within the within
the business plan the focus to date has
been around looking at the asset
register as it currently stands and
looking at the titles within their as it
as it stays in report we have some
titles everywhere or referring to radio
and district count
rockford raw district council it's about
bringing those up to date ensuring
accurate so doing some work with the
land registry and creating bead packs
for those titles and then we'll be a
goes into register at a later date to
make sure they're up-to-date and
accurate and reflect the actual current
terminal the current condition those
titles I said that will be working with
the Land Registry submitting evidence
and updating those titles through the
dpac process then finally having a a
finished version will those be more
up-to-date those titles being added in
moving forward lead that we're looking
at some some options of categorizing the
register making it easier to use easier
to analyze logo options going forward
initially we're looking at three
categories in terms of some assets or
early delivery phase if you like that
may we could look to develop in some way
also looking our assets on longer term
leases as a separate category what the
options for those going forward and also
to later dates are more charging sites
about options for those what do those
going forward as well in terms of our
own early delivery phase as listed on
the report will be looking at some
potential options and constraints
restrictions around some of those sites
working with colleagues in legal and
planning to see what that could look
like just to produce a an outline
summary of some ideas coming forward for
some of those sites and what that could
look like what that could yield going
forward in terms of next steps will be
looking to present some initial findings
initial review the register to project
sponsor to again 26 and more clarity
it's more direction about how they like
to see the project developed and move
forward to the next stage put that
summarizes the report happy to take any
questions that remember
what can you put any time scale cool in
terms of looking at the titles not
currently the register such as the
rayleigh urban colleagues in a legal
section at creating Deepak's now they
tell me by the end of May they should
depending on the map slightly strange
how long the land rush it takes to come
back to us they should be fully up to
date and then incorporated the end of
May that's what they're working to for
that part of that plan is meet with by
the end of april we hope to have some
initial early sites identified with some
early thoughts on that so i'll be
looking to meet with the project sponsor
and Mayor Lee sorts end of April early
May to present mask you know it's more
it's the same question you know just
like try to get a definitive time
bearing in mind you know if my stretch
of it because obviously valo research to
do yes especially on some of the older
beads and then so are you are you
confident that you'll actually be able
to bring it in on that time of the rail
urban yes within we are in terms of the
book there's a wider piece of work in
Santa reviewing all the titles win the
register which is a very hefty document
that's been much longer time scale my
proposes to do that I on a phased
approach so we'll be looking at taking a
a proportion of those and doing up a
phased approach going forward but for
the initial rayleigh open district we've
been the main without those up to date
and incorporated so basically what
you're saying is is that the whole
lesson register that will actually take
a bit little bit much longer piece I
life done deal with all joints are
trying to get act I think you were
trying to get at the same ready but
they'll be along a piece of word that be
categorized and phased banger what comes
out of the initial identification some
other sites will look at their nose
first and now going to face basis i can
adjust is just one question if you
mentioned about the end of a group in am
I how does this time with
further and all of us to bits and pieces
I mean this discard nothing you know
amount of this will have to go on hold
with me I don't know as far as purchase
from said but I think it doesn't affect
it doesn't make it okay my children just
going to be clear on its always saying
that the as it rich to publish in
September 2013 possibly or probably or
does not contain assets which are held
under Brady a hundred life stopped
raining Roger girl and Rayleigh urban
Urban Council yes separate yes there are
sometimes you're not included and there
which and don't appear in average those
the ones who take you to the initial
ways to get those corrected and accurate
working with the napa different is there
any significance pieces of been
identified another 25 it's like oh geez
that sort of thing which really what
started running is there anything of
significance in terms of those initial
radio oven oven call significant at this
stage and there are options for them but
now there wouldn't be a we're not
talking and significant ice they asked
once you describe some all our strips of
land that's some last others but nothing
significant but that will come fall with
the options that mall which could still
do it so we're talking to across those
you kept surrounding spruce and yes yes
I'm just asking about where we say their
assets on long-term leases now clearly i
know it says that these we consider the
later type phase of the review but what
sort of things are we talking about here
are we talking about those cycles we've
hired our assets that we've leased out
and clearly there may be these
situations where we could still continue
with that but we might get another other
company or something else to manage them
or or something like that are these the
sort of things that that sort of thing
and perhaps where it might be beneficial
for us to buy buy out the lease and look
at the development of the site so yes
various aspects or not okay yeah because
it's probably quite a few of those John
Mayer going forward and of course it
might not think most of them come up
something like every seven years or so
about 47 years yes the normal time in
seven years or multiples off so yes
we'll be looking options for that
chairman okay fine thank you very much
champion anyhow questions okay there is
a recommendation on page six point two
just breathe 3 item center oh yeah oh no
vm priorities outlines near the proposed
approach it may refers to the appendix
which is insulin projects in
installation government is not a working
document on how its country delivered
the key points real that there is four
stages proposed and I'm sorry girls
constantly first stages with
establishing a feasibility of like a
generic crematorium so you know before
we proceed to eat
that's why I wish to establishments and
take back at this stage so in many ways
of the ideas we look at or through
existing crematoria into the local
authorities ownership look at their
figures and then come back therefore the
ideas come to go through in short
timescales about four weeks time like to
come back and say this is roughly what
it looks like in terms of the needs to
run a credit or e is that something
we're still interested if it if so then
we go into the next stage of looking
would it work for Oxford one of the
Mercedes they do do they work generally
is that something we're interested in
selling that that's things is the paper
exactly you talking about so a pre is
this plane situation if there is such a
thing it is yes I'm so you know its
basics like these are the top line
figures up is there something we should
proceed that stage when they look at
start looking at the markets here to say
be a bit more nitty-gritty that's don't
again consultants will cease with taste
our assumptions we're gradually
preparing in the first part of the scope
exercise to get everything together that
we need to enjoy the facilitation with
de Fergus on the top of of April and
that will be the first day in which our
whole project team will meet for the
whole day to consider the scoping work
that we've got we will be delivered to
members of the project team beforehand
and obviously today focus be of this
facilitated session hopefully you know
we wouldn't be too far away from coming
back to the board with our initial views
one thing you do need to know is when
made some notes about it we spoke last
time generally above whether the pricing
and future sales of of cemetery plots
would be included in this project we
discussed that discuss it with the
project manager Marcus and we decided
not and I made a few notes because I
think you'd like to know why we
science to take that out for a start the
other cemetery opportunities are
actually ready to go the work is already
being done so it's ready to go with the
portfolio holder if we put it into the
crematorium project we could delay that
coming forward which I don't think would
be the best idea with those cemetery
opportunities coming forward it'll be
there me quite clear what we're
interfacing with in terms of the
crematorium and in terms of project
focus it could well be a distraction
from actually looking closely at the
focus on the scope of the crematorium
the other side of it is that particular
income as generated goes into the budget
and he's not actually been held to
ransom as part of a funding of the grand
touring project we need that cash things
go we heard about more cuts today so I'm
even more short but we should do to
preserve the benefit of that get rid of
that questions yes it's the third just a
load on another day day focuses matching
moved on from the geology so ready but
we're making items or someone similar to
its good things my GC moved on he's not
incremental right
he passed on colleges there'll be
someone like it will only have something
simply cannot man so the expertise can
be found so we're still going to go in
the top study sorry to you can I ask oh
so again what's up down baking partners
and paying attention a learner one of
you know it's just in regards to the way
in which that I would go about it mean
obviously will be coming back on the
twelfth we're going to have you know our
first project meeting of the group that
will be as good a time as any you know
to actually put together some of your
ideas that need to go in and see exactly
I take it we're going to have an outside
expert in this who had done quite a
similar amount of research and have
expertise within it so we'll be able to
ask him questions about where he has
gone how he's viewing it and how he's
actually preceded yeah yeah we're also
networking with other council that the
recently done this you know and done
some of the markets essence of example
Brian Terry something threw in a couple
weeks talent this is something that
there was recently gone through to be
losing how they had the conference to
decide to establish a crematorium what
marketing is off market and it took
three things that have in Atlanta the
information is there and available so
you knew something was going to be
interested to hear that dude bursts oh
I'm hoping the Marcus I will be able to
bring that forward so we can circulating
before the 12 so he very Chancellor was
all budget and they work on the previous
incumbent in this meeting that's not
still going to go ahead but a different
fellow was particularly qualified with
no he was once a unique but unusual if
do you really believe you're going to
get someone of the same caliber to be
able to sit in
we can't and that's something that will
rise but I think we should be able to
their bakery at this stage it is a
generic business plan looking taking for
so but surly for the more detailed stage
we're gonna have to find out more than
just one day to put anyone I think
releases this is broad brush approach
yes I think will be as funding for the
level of detail how broad is this thing
that is really relatively remote or solo
so hasn't got a full understanding of
the operation and viability of a
crematorium is appointed me to inland
whole point is is we haven't had a
project meeting yet is to give project
members the opportunity to get to grips
with the scope of wedging what we're
trying to do some might be quite
advanced in that some may not and it's
the opportunity to facilitate the next
stage which will be how do we go forward
from the point we you know we will have
heard from the experience of other
councils we weren't having the benefit
of the rulers Daniel and Marcus are
going to be doing I'll certainly be
overseeing it it gives us the
opportunity to put a skeleton together
and to put always have protected the
ashes in their ability hours that should
have been on a so people came through so
ever that's what I'm trying to get our
keys we've got to start with small steps
and those small steps are important it
would be very foolish to jump straight
in and call it I think a consultant to
the table who's experiencing crematoria
and when in fact we may not be able to
answer many of the questions the any
consultant is going to demand a briefing
and that is exactly our ambitions our
expectations consideration of location
how we what the funding we think is
necessary what the opportunities with
jv's are we need to cover all of those
before we see a consultant
28 yes and no I mean I missed the last
meeting on 40 as well but it is
proceeding we're working well together
their colleagues in county etc to take
you forward oh you are there yeah and
you know we're hoping to actually have
some fruit on this very shortly if you
want to comment on that tool Jimmy I
have to say a few words and perhaps
can't answer might yet might wish to
join in as well and I think I think
reiterate the point that this is making
good progress architects have have been
appointed in an hour working actively on
developing options for the site's
various lighting right rude and unkind
so Hudson attended the progress progress
meeting and saw a presentation we
raining hopefully 4am for cancer cut one
console Hudson to meet the the
architects and next week ten days or so
and there's a further progress meeting
on the twentieth of April when there
will be hopefully formed options coming
back from the project team and were our
ambition is to get a full report
prepared for consideration in in June
and that will conclude financial
appraisals of the
options so it's it's making making very
good very good progress perhaps the
object has been given our line brief
astral yes indeed they've been happy in
fully briefed in practice this week they
they they came down toward the the site
in rochford saw it yep they're up to
speed were already beginning to form
various ideas themselves so that's great
so we're hoping that that will actually
give us something really quite exciting
in due course too but again to consider
as Sean space i'm downloading a report
which is literally just come in from
winnowing yeah celebrity 17 megawatt
hours here i'll just sit and read it all
to you it's some is interesting meeting
they did want some idea of what we
thought would be acceptable as opposed
to to futuristic that's a content there
was one which looked like a boxer Lego
and i said that wouldn't really suit us
but i gave them some ideas of what
architectural features love it isn't a
completely none of the architectural
features that i thought members would be
[ __ ] tent within and those features
which only Sean could love it's so if
they've got off to commission the
initial studies with a very expensive
i'm told it's not our money so who cares
london-based architect company and
hopefully this reports are downloaded
maybe the first as part of it there's a
lot to it as you
the architects panty dropper they call
it let it burn slide so if you want to
google it later okay again but that's a
radiant yes what is worth this but it's
work is probably worth googling because
that there are videos I think with him
as a video on their on their website
that explains exactly what they're about
you know you know the really it's a top
form of architects so you know having
them working in in ruptured is it's
really very exciting indeed so I think
notwithstanding that there may be
different views on some of the some of
the examples that were showing it price
presentation I'm sure that you know it
will be it will be really quite exciting
to see what they what the commodes
induce guys decided a time spent so they
doubt start building I'm sayin well I
don't know what you doing I didn't is
two to one against keeps away it's still
as could I have your now dog wife Lila
died I think it's time to change the
team thank you very much baby boy that's
right baby wasn't it interestingly i
will just read this very short bit place
services as a company employed no have
been appointed to undertake due
diligence research on the site including
over design plan in ecology RB cultural
culture archaeology and historic
environment misty builders and
conservation highways and transportation
sustainable urban drainage this work was
reported as being undertaken and on
schedule so it's going ahead at a pace
he wanted to come it was it was just
basically with regard to the architect
effectively circulated to members so
that you know rather than just take it
as a as a thing we can just be so proud
to remember so we can actually have a
look on middle age is this is this a
difference in artist artistic hours brit
appreciation is with any queries are out
I mean I mean is it more we're looking
on the practical and the artistic is
just as I just want to try to describe
without I'm going to read this bit okay
this is very important summary of
dislikes any design likened to the Lego
style buildings which have been built
nearby super selling garbage sorry
they've got it if I mean the refuse to
settle into the building in something
south end that's multicolored that
others will oh boy they certainly a
legal building but you know funding the
one that picture of the money by rope
wasn't that brilliant what's in there
were several Alton tarala [ __ ] I'm
very much looking forward to the debate
in due course you are nobody of you but
Nathan mean abroad well what I want to
know does anybody actually worked out
how to read the plots on side of that
building is having yes I can't working
out from we go backwards oh it's going
to say chairman is that clearly the
things are moving on a pace I think
members have got clear involvement in
this I think that's the whole point of
the project but the whole point here is
to actually take things forward and to
maximize their assets going forward as
counsel has already said at the moment
where this issue we're not actually
using our money to actually melon this
so that's a really good thing proper
firm RT hips have been involved we're
looking at genuine designs genuine ways
forward to actually take this in to
enter if you like into I'll use the term
bricks and mortar but if you want to use
plastic brick for that's fine but I was
a lego man myself when I was young
but my older brother was mechano maid
McCauley yeah that's it which in it hits
on the how old you are I think where you
come from but having said that I
wouldn't like to see them necessarily
using the building and I think we all
look to the building that's referred to
in Southie I think well that's not
really suitable for ruptured so I think
it is something that would actually you
know if we're looking for designs purely
practical designs it's got to be
something that I think suits the temper
and and the way of rot should I think
and it's going to be sympathetic to that
and I think Castle Hudson I'm very sure
will it put that point across but of
course it's going to be functional as
well and it's going to be profitable I
wouldn't want to see our profits going
on something that spending on something
though just for the designer space
accidents between their you know a large
appropriately smaller profit for the
benefit of our community so I think
these all these things have to be taken
into consideration properly so you know
look forward to getting the report that
council Hudson's downloaded now taking
that forward okay hope you'll send their
halters possibly say that goes oh sure
catch me at one point and it's not meant
to be adapter in any way but understand
the point that's been made about finance
the date and actually we've done
fantastically well in terms of wheeling
out to cash from essex housing to fund
the project to date but members didn't
just need to be a word that you know if
we are going to move on to the next day
just wit as we call at that point the
council will have to think about to
think about friends support for the
project so we shouldn't lose sight of
that quote on yeah it's only about what
point to these things become
confidential I'm all for circulation
reports but should there be any
confidential
LT caveats put on anything that's
proceeding under that project obviously
the crema torium and others if as you
request chapman rd is perfectly
reasonable request this report was
provided to this group I would hope it
would be considered to be confidential
because clearly it's commercially
sensitive and it also there's lots of
options and suggestions here and folk
out there would not necessarily take
them as suggestions and options but as
we were before what they'd done the deal
and that's the sort of thing we don't
want to happen so if your instruction is
for me to copy this or I will lead
tareyton to forward it but I think
everyone needs to understand that it is
a purple paper in which case does that
also apply to the millions of this
meeting to those parts that are
sensitive as the thing this particular
project which is children i'm not i'm
not sure i mean i think i think probably
you gathered that there's that certainly
as far as the item we've just been
discussing it would be fairly sketchy in
terms of in terms of the information i
don't think there's anything untoward in
relation to reports that have already
been discussed but i think the point is
well meaning that you know we will need
to carefully consider the
confidentiality of this as persons each
of the projects progresses I think the
statements that we made so far I would
like them published in the echo the
kiddies real estate see where they go
top builders
but I haven't been dicated in the
suggestions that I purchased and
positive you hope that's what will print
yes any other questions okay so watch
this space chimp what's a smash yes
that's good with google para yes I think
the treatment energy is with increasing
patient okay item 9 is to receive her
probably update for portfolio hold of
the community and environment on the
country park projects as Johnny's not
here to anybody else that job just just
a brief outline we we did have a rather
sore relaxed informal meeting amongst
previously and we discussed a number of
options and went for a number of
different sort of like possible projects
that may come out of the discussions it
was very much brainstorming sort of a
hospital in session and and it is now I
think believe passed on the three
offices to look at in a little bit more
detail sometimes known if you want to
take you on from there just sickness and
clarity on the project sponsor people as
yourself near that Candace latone for
the country part type that has this lean
some sort of what we do is where we
arrange a meeting next week for me take
that forward now and again
flash answer after the project plan so
there was some confusion and this box
bed yes because they are both point
which was roasted our beautiful more
meeting that because of the development
which is going to be proceeding on
opposite Cherry Orchard would actually
introduce tourism which into the area
and that taking that into account was
the reservoir road in the meeting we've
suggested some of the activities to be
researched by the officers at that at
that point that's all we've got to
provide the group breakfast so how do me
more for the next week this and I don't
take of member sponsor for the hotly
ready project and I had a chat please
Carol who very kindly agreed that I can
propose to do that the little chain one
Robin like so able assists and thumper
members are happy that so much i hope we
will have the officers give you some
breathing and today etc södra cheering
yes both will arrange to the scent of a
meeting in the stove
or perhaps a bit little bit of a brief
outline by these things okay actually
have projects office then this may be a
sort of standing item and it may be
there's there's something to say on for
a lot to see happening is as things
stand at the moment that the word
project office has been doing has
covered the skills audit for members of
staff and members will be aware of that
of that piece of work I think the hints
for all the projects and one pages have
all been prepared there was a project
sponsor event which I think went very
well and there are various support
documents now being produced in in the
background and work is also taking place
in in terms of preparing the sort of
Gantt chart or spreadsheet of all the
projects here with timelines and so on
there's a little bit of work good going
on in terms of how that how that is
actually presented to think but like
that that's that's well under way as
well so those are the sort of main the
main points are I wanted to make it at
this point that though if I can take
that just also take the opportunity of
of throwing in just one other additional
update in terms of projects because one
of the issues that we're looking at as
members will be aware is is the creation
of a of a trading company or a trading
around whatever the year the terminology
for that is and I just wanted to
make a point for the minute that that
work is is progressing and ultimately
we're hoping to that and come back as
another of the reports in June you know
so that work is underway if cancer had
somewhat just that we had the first
meeting of that tomorrow at nine-thirty
with Nick calm yourself sir me someone
else Angela nor by remembers hope so
it's absolutely in its infancy and we
report back although we don't have any
other B's this is there anything away
this is to pass that we've hadn't put
any questions almost all spare very
projects
it's our liturgical